[Música]
cambio de tema la transmisión de los
premios de la academia de este domingo
estuvo cargada con todo lo que faltó el
año pasado por la pandemia ofreciendo un
trío de anfitrionas un regreso a esas
lujosas producciones musicales y una
gran dosis de comedia que incluso tuvo
un momento violento con burlas de crisis
rock y una siguiente bofetada que le dio
will smith en una ceremonia con cada vez
menos televidentes este episodio se hizo
viral pero en lo primordial los premios
varios galardones se adelantaron a la
transmisión y duna se llevó varias
estatuillas además en categorías
notables en campeones se quedó con el
premio a mejor directora por el poder
del perro' segunda vez que el galardón
no lo asegura una mujer por segundo año
consecutivo y co2 se convirtió en la
primera película de un servicio de
streaming en ganar el premio a mejor
filme además una afrolatina queer se
alzó como mejor actrices de reparto la
conversación no sobre esos y otros
detalles de la noche de los premios más
famosos del cine es desde ciudad de
méxico con esteban macías conductor
productor y crítico de cine esteban a
gracias por estar con nosotros y
empecemos con
fuerte en la gala ariana de voces la
actriz queer afro puertorriqueña y
criada en carolina del norte que ganó a
mejor actriz de reparto por west side
story' la interpretación de spielberg
del clásico hizo honor dentro y fuera de
la pantalla cuál es el mensaje con su
galardón
era un gusto poder charlar te saludar a
toda esta audiencia evidentemente es
importante lo que sucede con la tierra
de bolsillo mencionabas una mujer de
raza negra latina actual haya parados
con esa gallardía en el escenario dar el
mensaje que dio me parece bastante que a
de entrada así bastante rescatable y
bastante destacable pero también es
importante mencionar el caso de arianna
que sucede una situación histórica
porque este mismo personaje ya le había
regalado un oscar a hace algunos años a
rita moreno el personaje de anita en el
clásico de broadway west side story' y
alguna vez en este proceso de promoción
de la película tuve la oportunidad de
platicar con spielberg y me habla de lo
complicado que fue encontrar su reparto
pero en el caso de anita no lo fue tanto
porque acudió a todas esas huestes de
broadway que tantas ganas tenían de
hacer cine y evidentemente haciendo amor
sin barreras pues uno de estos grandes
clásicos bajo la tutela de quizá el
director más famoso del mundo pues
entonces sólo buenas cosas podían pasar
y eso es lo que sucedió
que está en la parte negativa pues hasta
donde tengo entendido ella mantiene para
broadway y a ver qué tanto puede dar el
brinco a las producciones hollywoodenses
pues bien ahora también hablemos de jane
campion con el poder del perro' segundo
año consecutivo que la dirección se
queda en una mujer el correcto primera
vez que sucede este en el espalda con
espalda y mira para para dimensionar la
importancia de este premio y hablaba de
steven spielberg spielberg ha sido
nominado a mejor director diez veces las
mujeres en la historia 94 ocasiones con
lo siguiente mujeres solamente 7
imagínate nada más y ganadoras 3 kathryn
bigelow hace algunos años y espalda con
espalda como mencionábamos claudia o el
año pasado por no matar y ahora jean
canción y más que destacable no sólo
este premio de dirección que sí me
parece importante porque además es la
única mujer con dos nominaciones en la
terna hay que recordar que el 93 por el
piano y ya llegó a estar mencionada no
lo ganó en esa ocasión pero ahora sí se
lo lleva pero es el único premio que se
acaba llevando el poder del perro y a mí
en esta introducción qué acción me
parece que es evidente el castigo de
hollywood a las plataformas de streaming
porque hay que recordar que aunque cada
ganador a mejor película si tuvo una
corrida muy importante en el streaming a
nivel mundial en realidad es una
película hecha para sombras hechas para
siles en muchos países como en el caso
de méxico se estrenó en las salas de
cine es decir lo premiaron una película
de su feeling y es el caso evidente del
poder del perro' dos denominaciones y
solamente un premio para chicas y vamos
a ir más rápido con las preguntas porque
tengo mucho que preguntarle y nos
quedamos sin tiempo y jessica chastain e
dedicó su discurso después de ganar a
mejor actriz al activismo contra el
suicidio y contra la discriminación
recuerdo el fallecimiento de su hermana
y para mí fue un discurso muy
protagonista hasta que will smith quitó
la atención de ahí con una bofetada
crisis roque que se burla de la alopecia
de su esposa y es que esto no es la
primera vez que pasa en 2016 ya venían
en una pelea cuando la lleida intentó
boicotear los oscar porque no nominaban
y no premian a su esposo a sus
brillantes actuaciones chris rock
también se burló en ese entonces pero
después de este acto bochornoso acto
seguido will smith gana el oscar
evidentemente si la bombita no tiene
nada que ver con el premio las
votaciones se cerraron de tiempo antes
entonces en ese sentido no tenía ningún
problema hay quien aboga por que le
retiren el premio will smith me parece
exagerado lo que y me parece también
exagerado de parte del actor es el uso
de la violencia puedes alojarte se
cuestionaba mucho que hasta donde tienes
que llegar a defender a tu esposa me
parece que la violencia no es del camino
y menos con el mundo que estamos
viviendo tú lo hablabas justo antes de
esta entrevista en el caso de ucrania
rusia no se puede ahorita estar
evidenciando la violencia de esta manera
y will smith se equivoca rotundamente
aunque incluso acción pesado en pasado
se haya burlado lo que sea es el humor
de este comediante y además si es famoso
que esta pareja jay wild son bastante
revoltosos son bastante abiertos con sus
expresiones y con sus quejas el premio
bien porque lo gana no es el que más le
gustó en cuanto a los nominados me
gustaba más benedict cumberbatch o
incluso antigases pero bueno will smith
se lo lleva bien una película que
también él gana pocos premios skin
richter y ahí está uno de iu sí creo que
el asunto de la cachetada opaca
muchísimas de las cosas positivas que
tuvo esta entrega digo no hay que
olvidar los que en algún momento estuvo
parado en el escenario pacino de lírico
con las juntos o travolta uma thurman y
samuel jackson proposición y otros
reencuentros pero me parece que la
cachetada opaca muchas de las cosas
buenas de esta transmisión
desafortunadamente el rating va a
regresar no y viene para guardar el
equilibrio de todas maneras se también
fueron violentos a su manera los
comentarios de crisis rock pero bueno
quiero ir a otra situación porque una
actuación esperada anoche por los
latinoamericanos era la de la canción de
encanto no se habla de bruno con
carolina gaitán sin embargo la gaita no
fue la gran protagonista de esta
interpretación y tampoco es la primera
vez que pasa lo vimos también en el
pasado con jorge drexler y antonio
banderas y me podría quedar dándole
ejemplos
usted cree que esto es reprochable
yo creo que reprochable pero también
tenemos que entender que al final es un
producto de la televisión norteamericana
para ese para ese público como prioridad
y si tienes toda la razón en el caso de
drexler
en el caso de cuando subieron si lo más
recuerdo
garcía también acataron una canción en
donde él es un poco más conocido y
acabaron teniendo un poco más de
representación por esa canción de luis
fonsi
pero me parece que no es tan
reprochables insisto su show que están
tratando de tener gente muy conocida en
el mercado de eeuu y quizá la gaita o el
propio mauro no sean tan conocidos en el
mercado de los eeuu de diferencia cuando
sebastián ya atrás que tiene un momento
importante aburrido es muy aburrido a mi
gusto pero es importante al estar
prácticamente solo con dos bailarines
ustedes sabrán más de esto pero bien
ataviados
particularmente con este sombrero
clásico colombiano que me encanta y creo
que en ese sentido pues si se le da un
poquito de peso y en el discurso de
agradecimiento de encanto evidentemente
agradecerle a toda colombia por el
aporte para esta película en cambio la
familia madrigal
a mi parecer tampoco me pareció que es
la mejor película de todas pero es
importante que la cultura
latinoamericana de una u otra forma esté
representado